et nous connaissons le mantra de la campagne
qui vient de se dérouler au cas où vous l'auriez
oublié vous l'avez probablement c'est
livrer le brexit unir le pays et
vaincre Jeremy Corbyn et surtout je
tiens à remercier notre dirigeante sortante
Theresa May pour son
service extraordinaire  pour ce parti et pour ce
pays, ce fut un privilège de servir dans
son cabinet et de voir la passion et la
détermination qu'elle a apportées aux
nombreuses causes qui sont son héritage, de l'
égalité de rémunération entre hommes et femmes à la résolution
des problèmes de santé mentale et raciale
discrimination dans le système de justice
pénale Merci Teresa merci